very unexpected we weren't expecting
will smith and his wife jada to turn up
on the red carpet the whole family here
posing for photographers but here they
are smiling greeting press nobody is uh
doing any interviews to talk about
exactly what happened but i suppose
this is the way that you deal with it if
you're if you're will smith come out and
you just put a smile on and and uh yeah
carry on with your night we've certainly
been trying to uh get hold of some of
the celebrities that were there tonight
and ask them what their thoughts were
pretty much nobody has wanted to uh
comment on what went on obviously will
smith is a hugely popular figure within
this town
and it was completely unexpected really
that this would happen it was a moment
certainly that seemed to just be a
moment of rage taking over and then
regret for the rest of the night you
heard in his speech really it becoming
an apology rather than a celebration of
his career
tonight we have also obviously in
response to what happened the academy
itself has ended up issuing a statement
they've said the academy does not
condone violence of any form
going on to say tonight we are delighted
to celebrate our 94th academy award
winners who deserve this moment of
recognition from their peers and movie
lovers around the world so they clearly
too
are keen to distance themselves from
that one moment of aggression but i have
to say kay
it is very unexpected to see will smith
here smiling a very different man to the
one who is picking up his uh best actor
award just a few hours earlier
here you go will smith back on the red
carpet smiling putting on a united front
with his family
what are the ramifications for him i
mean he literally walked on stage and
punched somebody
that is the thing it is a very strange
moment you would think that perhaps
there aren't many people really that
could get away with something like that
but we saw immediately
afterwards as well
within the industry
checking whether he was okay but it was
a
moment of an aggression a moment where
he certainly was out of control and
didn't seem to be
able to control that aggression during
the ceremony but here you see
he is uh determined to be
making the most of his night proud of
the award that he's won the best actor
and it would seem keen to move on from
the events of tonight i mean even
earlier today we heard uh tonight we've
heard lapd being asked to give a
statement about whether or not they are
going to be looking into this they've
said certainly they are aware of what
went on between these two gentlemen
during the academy awards but unless
somebody makes a complaint they won't be
pursuing it any further
but yeah it was a a moment of violence a
moment of raise from somebody who
certainly within the industry has a
reputation of being one of hollywood's
nice guys here he is
out smiling trying to to carry on as
normal
first time he's won an oscar
[Applause]
well he he has won an oscar 30 years and
he's had to wait for this and i suppose
if you've waited 30 years you do want to
have your moment but certainly this
evening
didn't go the way that he would have
liked didn't go the way he wanted to
plan he would have planned but i think
it is very telling kay that he's been
out here with the whole of the family he
wanted to show that he had
his family certainly wanted to show that
he had
their backing and their support
i mean we still don't entirely know what
this came down to we know that his wife
jada has very publicly been
speaking about her own alopecia her own
hair loss and it would seem that chris
rock perhaps had made
reference to her to a joke like that you
can see perhaps as a loyal husband maybe
that's what tipped him over the edge but
it was a very aggressive moment and
certainly a a moment that we wouldn't
expect to see from uh someone in his
position but yeah totally unexpected
really okay that he has turned up here
tonight after really what was a very
very strange uh oscar ceremony